welcome to the steam cell yeah hello everyone guys i i just
realized this week i've been fucking up like like on the
schedule i get it right but then like every time i make my
waiting room tweet i realize i always keep fucking up
daylight savings for like jst and gmt because i I don't pay
a debt I the reason why I keep fucking it up is because I'm
lazy and what I do is that whenever I make a waiting room
tweet I just grab an old tweet oh wait an old waiting room
tweet because I'd be like all right I'm streaming at 5 p.m.
let me grab a tweet I made for 5 p.m.
streams and I just go on Twitter copy paste as a template
and I go brother just change the title and the I don't have
to retype the times and I was like wait a minute what is
this doesn't look and then like later I was like wait a
minute wait daylight savings is a thing so I've been like I
realized I've been like fucking up the daylight savings time
for my waiting room tweet every time for the past week now I
just realized that I was like no My laziness!
Because why would I retype the time when I already have the
time on the waiting room?
I already have like a template for it.
I fucking hate daylight savings time.
It's only invented by like farmers.
Like we don't need daylight savings because we have to
revert it anyway.
That's the fucked up part.
Like later on in the year, we're just reverting our like
we're just reverting our change anyway so what's the point
let's just live a couple of months like let's just live a
couple of months where like you know the sun shows up later
than usual who cares global warming is already doing
everything anyway
if you think about it we already are getting fucked by
global warming so it doesn't matter savings.
Anyway, Freddy, thank you for the 100 gift of chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Also, Bacon, thank you for the 50 gift of chips.
Thank you.
Like, the sun's are, the weather's already fucked up.
Do we really need daylight savings?
Like,
it's true.
You only booed me because i'm right the weather is already
fucked we might as well live without daylight savings it's
like it's so fucked up right now in some places it's hot
when it shouldn't be in other places it's snowing when it's
fucking spring like what's going on but yet we have to worry
about daylight savings like but yet the farmers are in
control of the time
sorry so i had to get that out of the way like we have to
get out of the way um anyway vote on thank you this super
chat thank you thank you the only mistake farmers make was
grow food for other people.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So they give a super chat.
Farmers don't even use daylight savings.
It was invented by a politician who thought kids should get
more sunlight.
Oh my God.
That's so outdated.
Like guys, we need to like.
I will run for office and get rid of daylight savings time.
Vote for dokeybird for president in America.
As a Canadian, I will run for office in America to get rid
of daylight savings.
Oh, wait, I should go for Senator first.
I forgot.
Sorry.
Vote for Adoki to be like mayor.
And then later on, vote for me to be Senator.
And then don't worry.
I will become the House speaker.
And then like I'll make sure I will abolish daylight
savings.
because that's the only thing that matters clearly instead
of banning tick tock i will ban daylight savings anyway jl
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you actually um
actually yeah daylight savings was invented to save fuel for
the war effort during world war two thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you okay sorry i i i just i just need
to go through with that because like oh my god i hate
daylight savings so much i really hate it anyway so today we
are going to be doing steam cell so how this works uh knows
more politics than the average american i think that's like
i think like People outside of America knows more politics,
knows more about American politics than the average
American.
When you live in America, you make sure you know nothing
about American politics because it's, it's, you just don't
want to know.
But then the rest of the world, we have to know because
like, everything that happens in America affects the rest of
us.
So we're sort of forced to know what the fuck is going on
with you guys in America happens in america like the rest of
us is like we get like partially fucked
so that's why everyone outside of america is forced to know
what the fuck is going on because we're too reliant on on
what the fuck you guys do
except for the states you guys have you guys know all your
states we don't care i barely care about my own provinces do
not worry i barely okay maybe that's just a me thing i
barely care about what like the individual things within the
countries so like i don't know where what the fuck my
provinces are let alone what 50 state 50 states i almost was
like how many states are in america do you want like an x
amount of states in your country
okay i also don't even like i don't even know my own
national anthem i'll just say i know like the partially i
remember partially of my own national anthem and it's like
oh canada Our home and native land
And then like Jazz National Anthem
Because like when I used to live in Asia Like that shit
would play almost like every fucking day But like it's only
that part like it was like but I just remember that like
that's all I could remember and and then yeah that's the one
part I could remember and then but like I know in America
you guys is like what you have to do like the pledge of
allegiance every day and also the national anthem them um
every day like is that is that is that true i don't know i
just a lot of my knowledge about uh a lot of my knowledge
about like uh like the america about america comes from tv
so i don't remember like i just need you guys to know a lot
of the knowledge i know about what's going on in america is
from your tv shows so like i i just know like i remember
just watching TV and they're like time to stand up to do the
pledge of allegiance and then I don't even know like I
haven't pledged in years but yeah but that's for school
that's what I'm saying for school oh you guys stop now the
TV lies I'm pretty sure like a lot of people like outside of
America learn about what's going on in America via your TV
shows like
the TV version is better than the actual version that's just
life general.
Van, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wow, Canadian net gets it.
I knew it.
There was a reason I enjoyed your content.
Besides, all along, we used to do the pledge in schools, but
they stopped that a long time ago.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
JL.
Yeah, we have to do the pledge.
Some schools even enforce it.
And thing about under God, that didn't get added to the
1960s.
They give the super chat.
Thank you.
That is why you should vote for Doki for Senator because I
will make sure I will add the ban of daylight savings time
but don't but i i just need you guys to know by the way you
guys didn't register this this is a joke please don't write
my name in any ballots in america please i do not want to
get into national tv for like compromising the vote system
in america because you guys have bigger things to worry
about
for legal reasons do not write my name in the ballot okay do
not please do not write my name in any voting in any in any
presidential or senator vote in your in your city i need you
guys to know this because if you guys don't know um if a
person gets you know this because where I say don't do it
and then people are like you know what I'm gonna do it
anyway because it's gonna be funny but I'm but if you guys
didn't me telling you guys this right now if you guys didn't
know if a person has a lot of like if a person gets a lot of
the written in ballots their name actually gets published
out out to be like a lot of the written in votes were for
this person so if a lot if enough people actually write
their name on the ballot it actually gets published out but
like please don't do that
Please don't jeopardize Please don't jeopardize a boat in
your city Josie, thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you Dokey for Secretary of Defense Thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you But it would be so funny,
Dokey You guys Guys, for all the For all the dragos living
in America right now.
You guys have bigger things to worry about right now.
Holy God.
I know there's some of you that are on the fence, but I am
not the one that's going to be convincing you on which way
to vote for.
So don't vote for me.
And you're written in ballot.
Anyway.
Off to like the The steam at spring you sell.
But it's the only way I will pay attention to politics,
Doki.
It's the only way.
As a Canadian.
Dragoons.
I do not think that that is the right way to go.
Anyway.
Where was I?
But yes, for those who have never done a steam spring cell,
who has never been to a steam, not just a spring cell, for
the steam cell streams before, how this works is that, uh,
how this works is that, uh, also if you guys really do want
to, I would be a terrible, by the way, I'm getting off
track, but like, I would, I would, I would be a very
terrible, like, politician, because I would definitely take
bribes.
so like uh like if you're lobbying for anything and you have
enough money i will 100 would take that bribe so please i
would be a terrible politician you're like but they already
do take prize anyway here up thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you um uh anyway as i was saying uh as i was
saying uh for those who have never been to a steam sale
before um uh what we do is that you dragoons would be
suggesting games for me and then uh we're gonna be watching
the trailer we're gonna like read the description together
we're gonna look at the comments section and then you guys
actually have the power to decide if if they have a good
game choice so i will be putting up a poll for all of you
guys and then you guys vote yay or nay when it comes to
buying uh when it comes to like buying the game so you have
like the power if like a dragoon suggests a good game but I
need to also let you guys know suggest games that you think
that you think will interest me it might be your favorite
fucking game of all time but is it a dokey game
you have to remember is it a donkey game like it could be
the best game in your opinion the best game in the fucking
world but is it the best game in the fucking world for me
like just remember that um Lewis thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you hello donkey struggling game
developer here Please check out Eden Growl.
Thank you, listen, Richard.
Thank you.
Um, all right.
Maybe I'll do Eden Growl as the, okay.
Oh my gosh.
I see some fucking crazy crashes.
The, all right.
Also, the other gamble is the, the, okay.
So like, now that I'm a streamer, because in the past, you
know, like, like ever, like I was just like you guys, the
Steam Cell would go on.
And then all of us would like pick up games and stuff, but
we will only play like one or two games of all the games we
buy on the steam cell the advantage of being a streamer now
is that now um especially because it's a single player uh i
tend to like stray away from single player games before i
became a streamer because uh uh you know like i just played
multiplayer all the time uh because it's like you buy like
200 games and then you go and play fucking out on minecraft
That was me.
That was like before Steam Cell was a thing, too.
The Humble Bundles.
I would buy like so... I would like subscribe to the Humble
Bundles because I was like, whoa, look at all the fucking
bargains from the Humble Bundle.
And then I would touch like one of the games from the Humble
Bundle.
Only one of the Humble Bundle games actually interests me.
And then I just like... That was the only game.
I would have like 300, like 100 games from the Humble
Bundles.
And I will only touch like three of them overall.
But now that I'm a streamer, I can like share the games with
you guys But like as in like I'll stream for you guys Not
doing anything legally Not doing any family plan here
I meant share Share with you as in you guys live by
curiously through me By watching me play those games So yeah
anyway So yeah that is how it's gonna go Let me see what is
the first suggestion The first Oh I am not playing kinuto
pet.
I heard about the the kinuto pet doing doxing shit and also
I was like I uh Goomy played it and I was there on her
stream.
I was in a voice call with her while she played it on
Oh yeah thank you the super chat thank you.
Thank you!
Radiance Toki please ban steam cells.
Thank you for accepting my prize.
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah I'm trying to see which one to go first.
Which one that like...
Which one I should like...
Give you guys to vote on first.
There's so many choices to vote on.
The Samurai game.
But that game is so mediocre.
Also.
I have three vetoes.
No no.
I have four vetoes.
Just so you guys know.
I have four choice chances to veto a game.
If you guys suggest a game that I know for sure that I do
not want to play, I will veto it, but I'll have four.
I can only do it four times.
All right.
Okay.
Amid evil.
Fast pace.
Nervous.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I don't think you had prunes.
I think you would love a jockey.
Cheers from a long time fan.
All right.
Let's look up.
Amid evil.
Isn't that the scary one?
Wait, I think I've seen this before.
Whoa.
Have we watched this before?
Oh, it's like, it's like retro, retro boomer shooter.
It has a volume.
Oh my god, you can punch the enemies.
That's not my favorite part because I like to shoot from
the...
I realize, I realize why melee when can shoot.
I can never do...
Oh my god.
I recently was playing Returnal recently.
And like, and like, Returnal is so fucking frustrating.
It's so frustrating.
Holy shit.
I might play Returnal on stream.
Returnal is basically a rogue-like shooter.
And it's, it's like Toho rogue-like shooter.
It's so fucking frustrating.
Hmm.
It's so hard.
the black labyrinth.
Wait, but...
Does he have gun?
Why is it all melee?
Where's this gun?
Amid evil, out now.
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
Where is this gun?
Alright, amid evil.
Yay.
or nay it's your choice guys you guys get the vote all right
let's see what the oh it's from the same people as dusk and
ultra kill i love ultra kill i don't want i'm gonna wait
until ultra kill is finished finished before it's out of
like uh beta before we do like ultra kill again uh all right
let's see another low-key game which puts triple a series
and publisher to shame That Battlefront Remastered did not
do so well, man.
Guys, did you guys see that fucking battle, the Battlefront
game that was like 75 gigabytes?
That is like, I think that's like bigger than Dead Space
Remastered.
That's actually, how does that get passed?
Okay, so like, I saw that they were tweeting out early
access codes too for this game.
So it's like, how did no one complain about it during early
access?
like how did no how did no one complain about being like um
so i was trying to download this game in early access and it
was 75 gigabytes like how did that not like how did that not
tell anybody that something was wrong wait they did they did
and they still did nothing about it i still can't pronounce
the devs I just noticed a medieval pun in the name.
Wait, what?
A medieval?
What's the...
What's the pun?
Okay, let's see.
Definitely not a medieval.
Why is this guy complaining?
You know, I want to see, like, okay, I try very hard to like
this game, but I just couldn't...
Okay, let's find the one negative comment so I can justify
me not buying this game.
You know, like, those people, when they try to look at
reviews and they always find like the one the one negative
comment and be like look see there's a negative comment that
means i shouldn't buy it and then it's like the one comment
the one negative comment out of like hundreds of comments
like there's always one see the game is not perfect why did
you guys suggest this game to me look see if it was perfect
there would Not wrecked.
There will be zero negative comments.
I really love this game.
Not recommended.
Alright.
I love retro shooters like Quake and Doom.
And I thought I could enjoy this one.
However, I found this game very frustrating for a number of
reasons.
The level design is very irritating.
Hidden paths in the platform.
This guy.
What?
It just seemed like this guy doesn't like retro shooters.
That's basically retro shooters.
Like.
Like what do you mean?
hidden paths and the hidden paths that's it based off of
entirely of retro shooters enemies are like flies as long as
they stay away from them and use a range weapon so game is
very easy oh i like that oh it's not hard enough okay the
movement absolutely sucks the velocity feels so unreal i say
this game might be worth it to try on sale but i wouldn't
pay oh my god lucky for me it's a steam sale
We got a yay on it.
I don't know how much time to give you guys to vote.
I'll just each.
You know what?
It's to my discretion.
So sometimes, sometimes they get, you guys get a lot of
chance to vote.
Sometimes you guys don't.
It's up to my discretion.
Welcome to the Dokiverse.
So, all right.
Yay.
Our first game.
A medieval.
Medieval.
Okay.
I just noticed the, I just noticed the pun.
I just noticed the pun.
medieval brutal legend okay that's the that's the game with
uh jack black right uh red force thank you the super chat
thank you thank you i've bought brutal legends for at least
six of my friends so far because i love the game so much uh
may interest you you might not but it's a major cult classic
is this the one with jack black i remember buying brutal
legends when it first came out on console.
It was like, oh my gosh, I remember by, and then, did I ever
finish?
I don't think I've ever finished it, but like, I played up
until, like, a while.
God, it was so long ago.
This game is so old.
It's 20s.
This game was 11 years old.
Jesus.
Oh my God, you can tell it's old.
Oh my God.
I still can't believe Jack Black is going to be in Minecraft
as Steve.
I still can't believe he got casted in Minecraft.
Of all things.
It would be a dream to collab with Jack Black.
What if I like...
Oh my god, what if...
Okay.
I'm going to switch Mr. Man and...
ask him if he could pitch to Jack Black's PR team if he ever
wants to collab with a VTuber.
I will pay for his VTuber model.
DMCA music?
It's alright.
I mean, fucking Freebirds already DMCA'd.
Oh, they're gonna DMCA this stream.
I just realized!
Fuck!
Okay, whatever.
I don't need Admiral.
revenue on this stream it's okay I don't I don't need add
revenue on this stream guys I don't need it by the way I
still haven't been paid okay I still haven't been paid by
YouTube so like I technically don't have like an income yet
uh YouTube side thank God I did have my merch store like to
compensate because I didn't know this but like when you're
starting out a channel um you have to make a um a ad revenue
account and like you need like a pin number that they send
over via mail and like um like the for so it says in two to
three weeks it would arrive and so let's get ads sent so for
those this is like a little pro tip for you guys because
like obviously this isn't like like obviously it's not like
common knowledge because for those who've never been like
monetized on what they do is that to activate your AdSense
account you need like a pin number that they send you that's
exclusively for you but the thing about that is that they
send it physically to your house or like to like to wherever
you live so like it says like there's no tracking too so it
says like it's like two to three weeks it's supposed to get
there and like the thing is So I was like, it's been a month
And I still haven't received it So I requested another I
requested them to send it again Because I was like, okay
It's been a month now Because I asked like my friends about
it And they're like, yeah, like Yeah, it should take like,
it took me like three weeks to get it So I was like, okay
Three weeks is the maximum that I'll wait for it But then
three weeks passed And I was like, maybe four weeks weeks
i'll wait four weeks maybe something's going on and then
four weeks i was like okay i should request again
so so like so technically i i haven't received any money yet
because like they also pay you at the end of the month so
like i was like okay maybe by the time i get my pin number
month but like so then I was like okay I'm just gonna have
request again
Scott thank you for the 50 gifted chips thank you thank you
yeah so I'm just like waiting again I'm gonna wait again to
see but oh yeah I forgot the vote I thought I had the vote
on guys oh shit did you gift it twice I'm sorry if I didn't
see I thought you give uh did you give the hundred oh my god
no it was once okay oh my god no it was once sorry it just
bugged out on chat okay brutal legends is voting time okay
brutal legends yay or nay yeah you guys had like so much
time to vote for this um but yeah it's quite like
unfortunate indeed but like that means when I do finally
have my AdSense account it would be a it would be like two
months worth of payout that's for sure like that's that's a
good thing I get two months of payout by the time I do get
my pin uh but yeah it's a little pro tip like don't expect
yourself to get the get like monetized like get the money
right away from youtube make sure you have a backup plan
thank god i have a merch store i did not realize like how
much money you can make off of merch it was crazy i was like
thank god thank god i opened a merch store alongside of me
coming back here because like that's practically my income
right now That's...
Because, like, I do have the money from that.
Like, it's a good thing.
It's a good thing.
Surgeon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
First ever super chat.
Might I suggest and shout it?
Thank you for the super chat, Surgeon.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Awesome game, what an amazing sound.
I heard they got a lot of, like, old rock bands for the
brutal legend.
and metal bands were this um this is like oh my gosh a while
back though uh i'm surprised brutal legends has not been
remastered yet because like um you know a lot of game
companies love to bank off nostalgia factor so it's like
very surprising to me that they have yet to like remaster
brutal legends because uh it's dmca central yeah it's dmca
because it was a game made before like people stream stream
and stuff but still i feel like i guess like getting rights
would be really difficult too yeah you guys didn't know
about music rights um usually for games they only have a
license for music stuff for like a specific amount of time
and then after that when the music license expires um they
have to like replace the music with something else or they
can never re-release it so like if brutal so like some games
and some movies the reason why they don't get remasters or
remixed is because the music license expire and it's so
fucking expensive to get the music license that they just
say no they just say they're just like yeah no we don't want
to deal with that it's way too much money it's too much
money to remaster and give this to you what is this i will
forever hate this game tried so many times to get it through
uh over the past decade why do you hate this even on easy
mode i can't get past the ghost rate part halfway through
there's reason why there's a reason why no one has ever
tried a mashup of these styles and game like this since it
just doesn't bro why are all these negative comments they're
just shit at video games like anything that's literally a
skill issue i'm sorry mickey for putting you on blast but
like what do you mean even on journalist mode i can't get
past the ghost raid part halfway through okay there it is um
there it is the one negative comment most helpful would have
been good if it kept the hack and slash but the rts is awful
and near the end gets impossible I look, there it is, my
token negative comments of the day.
All right, let's see how long you guys vote for it.
All right, yay!
All right, next, Brutal Legends.
That is a yay from all of you.
All right, next game.
Have you played Alien Isolation?
Yes, never again.
Zach, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We have part one.
If you look around, you will find the archives.
That's all I can say.
All of my previous stuff I played.
If you look hard enough, you will find an archive of it.
That's all I can say.
I will not replay it.
I will absolutely not replay it.
Master Chief Collection.
Thank you for that machenta soup.
Thank you.
Master Chief Collection is 75% off right now.
Since you said...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
this one um i feel like i don't even need to like have you
guys vote on it we're just gonna watch the trailer this
doesn't need a sorry but you're not permitted to view these
material at this time why not oh okay was i just not old
enough like i'm like what do you mean i'm not permitted okay
we can watch the fucking trailer um we don't even need to
vote because it's obviously gonna be a yay i i know for sure
you guys are just gonna vote yay for this but i can play
halo now i've never played halo before i've never because i
never grew up with xbox so i have no idea what the fuck halo
really is i don't know the story of halo the most things i
know about halo is red versus blue because of uh rest in
peace rooster teeth uh i can't believe ruby graduated
Weird year There's so many so many like old school YouTube
people are like done with YouTube It's actually crazy Yeah,
rest in peace and like Ruby just became like a fucking
Vtuber too They actually became like Vtubers till that it's
been three months.
I know it's been three months It's like a lot of like all
the old-school stuff has been like super they've just like
either retired quit or or just graduated it's actually
insane to think about yeah Ruby was an official VTuber it's
actually interesting too because like obviously we're not
voting for this because we all know that's obviously a yay
is there a bad halo game in this collection but the reason
why I've never played an Xbox I I never played Halo before
is because Halo was an Xbox exclusive and I've never played
I've never really the only Xbox I own was the Xbox 360 for
those who didn't hear the story before they're all good all
of them maybe for the newer the game the worse it gets
because money but you guys didn't know I never grew up with
Xbox because my dad's a gamer and he's a sony fanboy because
he loves playstation so he's a he's a playstation fanboy so
like when i'm going up we've only owned playstations i never
like had a a nintendo console until until like the end of
the game to game cube life uh and i only was able to get it
because it was like for my birthday and i was like begging
for a game cube because i never own a nintendo console
because my dad would be like uh nintendo's for babies i'm
like but i am a baby you know
i was like those nintendo's were fucking babies no nintendo
in this house and i'm like but um i'm baby
so so i never had a chance so the only time I ever got like
a Nintendo console was the GameCube the moment it was dead
like there was no new games coming out so there was a
bargain for that console and I only had two games on the
GameCube because there were no new games coming out and I
didn't know what to buy and my dad was like you can pick
usually you know when you head to like um in Canada it would
be like EB games so my dad would be like you can only pick
one game and then obviously I would choose a PlayStation the
really good game the new games come out on the PlayStation
so I had to so I was just like so I would pick PlayStation
games versus old-ass GameCube games and the only two games I
owned on GameCube was Animal Crossing and um um chat like
the shadow Pokemon games I don't remember what to call like
the shadow pokemon games those are the only two games I
owned on the game cube and that was it yeah call it CN and
XC sorry three of them because I bought the sequel too I
bought the sequel of the shadow one too so those are the old
so yeah I never grew up with an Xbox the only time was Xbox
360 because my dad like wanted to play like some Xbox
exclusive game on the Xbox 360.
And even then, I didn't even, I didn't play Halo.
I didn't play Halo.
Oh, I think it was Gears of War.
Yes, the only reason why my dad bought the Xbox 360 was for
Gears of War.
That was the only time.
That was the only reason why we had it.
And then after that, we never bought an Xbox console since.
It's like...
Anyway, next game.
Sorry, story time.
I'm pretty sure like all the Halo...
Halo, good.
Halo Reach broke me, but Halo 2.
You know what?
That sounds reasonable.
Nice.
Those are good reviews.
Nobody will read my review.
So I'll just say I'm gay.
Nice.
The chat is going so fast, they'll never know.
They'll never know, guys.
Oh, shit, our token negative comment.
A wonderful slice of nostalgia ruined by a toxic community.
What does that have to do with Halo?
That just has to do with the fan base.
Like, the developers can't control what's going on on the
fan base.
Like, that's not their fault.
What do you mean?
Also, like, this guy's a pussy because, like, every
multiplayer game has a fucking toxic community.
Like, you can't...
Like, the first time I ever queued up for Valorant, people
were fucking saying gamer words to me.
And I was like, what?
And it was the first... And it was on Valorant launch.
Like...
Like, it was the launch of Valorant.
Like, if a game... Game can't control shit.
And the people are fucking toxic on the launch of a game.
It's just always... It's just the Multiplayer Syndrome.
It's just...
It's called competitive multiplayer.
Like...
Alright, let's see.
What else?
What else do we have?
Doki Good.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It ain't multiplayer.
People aren't salty.
Exactly.
What is self-park?
It'll be funny.
Please, please, please.
Okay, this one doesn't need to be voted on because I 100%
won't play.
um the self the was strapped uh the fractured but whole yes
a fractured but whole yeah sorry i've always wanted to play
that on stream so don't worry about it i'm definitely not
gonna play the first one i might try to get the australian
version just to like not get like it to i don't know if
there's like super controversial jokes in the sequel to the
self-park game i like 100 complete 100% complete games
except for the stick of truth the stick of truth might be
the first game I ever 100% it because I really enjoyed that
game but like I played the original game without the
Australian censored version because I mean it's smart
because the original game had a lot of stuff in there that I
don't know if I can stream it So I feel like, I feel like, I
feel like if there's, if it's very similar, if it's very
similar in, in the sequel, I might need the Australian
version.
I might need, just maybe, because I don't want to get my
channel flagged.
Let's see.
What else?
4.1 shadow of new despair trust Liam thank you for the
magenta super thank you thank you all right what is this
earth defense force the only thing i know about this game is
that um it's very popular in speed running communities
especially in ag dukey dk df bc edf super scout news It's
time for EDF Super Scout News.
The EDF has been reporting nothing but victories around the
clock for days on end.
As we speak, the battle is entering a new phase.
We'll fill you in on that and give you the latest
information.
EDF!
Oh, the other... EDF walked so hell divers can run.
Walking Fortress Balam was...
Deployed to oppose the Argynous, giant creatures that
appeared from the ocean.
This dependable powerhouse is mankind's mobile stronghold.
And now, equipped with new weapons, it's achieved
perfection.
Look at its power, stronger than ever before.
Well, I could win without it, yeah.
But it helps for sure.
You sound confident.
I love democracy.
Where's the game?
Oh, there's the gameplay.
I was like, where the fuck is the gameplay?
Wait, how many people can play?
There's so many people!
The environments, the type and number of enemies, and the
locations in which they appear, can change drastically.
Oh my god, it's the roguelike, because it changes.
There's robots.
I love robots.
Oh, wow.
four okay is this like the best EDF was just because there's
so many something is the best one but anyway yeah things
really do look sharp so this is that 1080p everyone's
talking about things look pretty real underground as well
and the jankiest edf five is the best why did you suggest
4.1
why all right if we do yay or nay we're gonna have you guys
vote for wish edf though it's quality which makes it the
best it's the best all right we're gonna have you guys vote
for 4.1 or 5 US officers.
Jesus Christ, this is a nine minute trailer.
We're not watching nine minutes of this.
All right, all right.
Clearly, this is a yay.
So I'm going to make another poll.
EDF, which version?
EDF 4.15.
Bro, why is this nine minutes of trailer?
What?
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Kind of like held 2.
If Helldiver's 2 Wait.
Okay, that's good.
That's pretty good.
Not gonna lie.
Helldiver's 2 servers at max capacity.
So I gotta play the next best thing.
Super fun to play.
Helldiver's 2 if it was...
Whoa!
Bro, shots fired!
Bro, he put that review at 5.4 hours.
Bro, how do you know?
Oh, Jesus, if it was good.
Oh, my God.
Bro, that's rough.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
You guys can't watch nine minutes.
Not nine minutes, but you guys can watch more of this
trailer.
I'll be right back.
It's in a lifetime chance.
Brent EDF has four branches, and your duties will vary
depending on which one you join.
But right now, in this specific case, the choice is up to
LSTs.
Okay, let's take a closer look First the Rangers
thoroughbreds that race across the world Just look at that
stance not an ounce of fat anywhere Look at how fast he
stands up.
It's amazing.
He doesn't get a head rush as leaders They can heal everyone
who follows them proving that nice guys don't always finish
last We'll show you how tough we are Next up wing divers
angels who dance through the skies.
Their flight suits are highly flexible and maneuverable.
Sexy too, but more than that, they're stronger now than
ever.
Perfect in every way.
Don't worry, we're on the same team.
Let's have fun out there.
Air Raiders dominate with their command of bombardments and
airstrikes.
Summon new weapons like Walking Fortress Balam or
Deathcrawler, then climb on in.
Major mounted weapons are now equipped with laser sights.
So even beginners can mow their enemies down.
All units commence operations.
Give them hell.
Finally, the steel giants we call fensors.
Their armor has been reinforced to godly levels and
obstacles mean nothing to them.
Their boosters and thrusters can not only increase their
speed, also keep them on balance why is there zero votes
what's going on with the poll what did i break the poll why
is there zero votes true democracy because they're both good
okay that means you have to buy both of them wait actually i
think five one wait edf okay edf five one okay earth uh
defense Okay, where's five?
Oh, wait, it's on sale, too.
Wait.
Recount.
All right, all right.
We'll vote for an EDF again.
We're going to do another vote for EDF again.
At the end of the stream, we'll let you guys vote for, like,
which EDF?
At the end of the stream, okay, guys?
Who said I wasn't just?
I thought 6 was like not out in NA yet.
Okay, I already like EDF 5 more because it's not a 9-minute
trailer.
Mom, can we buy EDF?
Can we play EDF?
We have EDF at home.
EDF at home.
Helltivers, too.
Look, it's 2 to point.
guys the trailers to the point it instantly told me
everything i needed to know in edf in within a minute
instead of nine minutes i killed god and yet ants on the
highest difficulty are extremely stressful what a magical
game fun with friends if you have them oh my god bro are you
oh my god that's why he has 0.3 hours Bro!
Bro!
This poor man!
He only has 0.3 hours on record!
Oh, bro!
Bro!
Okay, it's his old account, bro.
Bro.
Guys, I don't think we can defend him, guys.
I know you guys really want to, but we have to face reality,
guys.
All right, next game suggestion.
What's this?
One vote for Grooman.
Sean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What the fuck is this?
What is this?
Massive.
Falcom.
What is this?
When did this game come out?
Is this RPG?
This is an RPG.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
Okay, I love the faces of the monsters.
Oh my god!
I love those types of faces.
They're so cute.
Oh my god, monkey.
We need our monkey.
remote back this
feels oh this definitely feels like a psp game while
watching this this definitely it definitely feels like a psp
game i don't know the thing is it's an rpg game that okay
all right let's that's like the biggest part i see rpg and
i'm like i think the last time i've ever played last time
i've ever actually played an rpg game um was was it neo the
one from the creators from from level five ah fuck was that
was that what it's called that was the last rpg game i've
ever played uh and like no it's not neo sorry oh noita is it
no okay is nino kuni nino kuni yes yes it's about that
little boy that's all i could remember the nina kuni and
like this like pig guy that's all and i only played up to an
hour and then i gave up the only reason why i tried it is
because i am a level five like fangirl and i i love level
five's like animation style and everything and like yeah i
only the that was the last time i've ever played and rpg
game because i i could only do one hour of that because i
was just like oh my god this is
i just could i could not i don't i don't see stick of truth
okay not gonna lie i don't see like i know like you guys are
like yeah but it's based off of like dungeons and dragons i
i don't see stick of truth as an rpg it transcends rpg like
get it no no no no self-park stick of truth is not an rpg it
is beyond that it is a god's gift okay i shouldn't say that
that's actually really fucked up that i said if you play
stick of truth that's so i'm so sorry
Let me rephrase it.
The Stake of Truth is like just, it is such a good game that
it has no, it has no category.
It has, it is, it is an adventure.
It is like, it is like an experience.
It has no category underneath it.
So, so it's not an RPG.
It is an experience I refuse to categorize that as an RPG Oh
wait, I lied Baldur's Gate was my last RPG I just Guys, I
couldn't I played Baldur's Gate for like 3 to 4 hours Like
Baldur's Gate 3 I forgot about Baldur's Gate 3 Anyway, the
last RPG I played was Baldur's Gate 3, and, um, I just
wasn't into it.
I'm sorry.
I'll say it.
I just not wasn't into it.
I know that RPGs is just something that my FPS brain rotted.
Like, my FPS rotted brain couldn't, like, couldn't, like,
commit to.
it's a really good game I heard it's a really good game I
tried it but my fucking I my brain has already been like
rotted from all the FPS games I played that I couldn't sit
down for Baldur's Gate 3 long enough but I but you know what
makes me better than some of the other Baldur's Gate 3
gamers I didn't cheese the dice roll I fucking committed to
it No matter what, I'm already above some people in Baldur's
Gate Because I didn't reset when I didn't get my dice roll
Like some other pussy
Anyway, that's Alright, let's see Originally a Japanese PC
game released in 2004 Oh my god, 2004 I thought that was
just a stylistic choice I mean, it makes sense now uh it
makes sense um uh grew in walks a high fire rush crude run
oh wait is this like similar to high fire rush i actually
really enjoyed high fire rush that was a nice game i'm glad
it won something does somebody else quit right before the
final boss because he couldn't figure out what to do okay um
as much as love the old falcom this felt rather uninspiring
seems close to Zelda than other series by the same wait what
other series do they do anyway I thought Russia's not an RPG
it's a hack it's like a hack and slash it's more like in
hack and slash than it is an RPG what do they do what are
games are they done I have no idea what any of these games
are I have no idea What any of these games are Wait is this
even on Oh it is Four dollars Holy shit It's only four
dollars What the fuck Alright Oh my god Okay
Okay I don't want to use my video on this.
I feel like I could use my video on other things
I feel like I feel like I don't want to I don't want to use
my video on this game
Alright You know what game I can't wait to play?
Digimon world But the good one is this the good one?
Is this the sequel?
Is this a good one?
Has Ram...
No, this is the...
Wait, no.
Actually, wait.
Which one is the remastered Digimon World?
Is it Digimon Sur...
No, which one's the remastered?
Wait, this is not the remastered, right?
There's no...
Okay, to be fair, there was one good Digimon game.
And it was...
Okay, like, as I meant...
Okay, I shouldn't say that because, like, Digimon fans...
They're so divided on what is a good Digimon game Because in
Pokemon it's more it's easier to tell what's a good Pokemon
game But like in Digimon, it is Digimon fans cannot agree
what is a good Digimon game Because like every Digimon game
there's something wrong with it There's something wrong when
they did it every single time it is very divided so no one
is gonna actually agree what is considered a good digimon
game because everybody don't know what is considered a good
digimon game but personally my favorite digimon game is the
original digimon world but that is because of nostalgia
factor and i thought it was on i thought the remaster was on
Steam.
What happened to it?
Wait, what happened to the original Digimon?
Wasn't the remaster on I thought the remaster, or was it on
console?
Was it on console?
Or like... No, it came out!
I saw it!
I remember it came out!
It's next order?
No way!
It does not... It's not next order.
I know for a fact it's not... It came out on uh on pc
because I saw it I I saw it no I did they remastered the
first Digimon was it called Digimon world okay it was like a
PlayStation game it was a PlayStation 1 game and I played it
and then and and then they like remastered it and then they
PSP they put it on PSP i'm so sad i'm so sad i thought it
was on i thought it was on pc who the fuck uses the psp do
people still use the psp i did not realize the psp is still
alive i did not realize i'm so sad now i didn't realize it's
still alive like who the fuck who the fuck i'm sorry for
that still owns a PSB.
But like, why?
Why do you go outside and play on the PSB?
I can't stand the PSB's landing.
But the screen is bigger on the PC.
Me with my PSB.
speed okay all right i'm sorry i i'm just sad that it's not
released on pc guys okay i'm just look i'm just salty it's
not released on the pc okay guys i'll say it i'm sad i wish
it was on the pc uh kuro thank you for the magenta soup
thank you thank you highly recommend pray it's
with that oh wait isn't isn't this wait do we have a vote
for this before I feel like I feel like we watched this
trailer before isn't that the that's the she got you I was
gonna say it I was like I was gonna be like I was gonna be
be like wait isn't that with the asian guy but that's like
wait i don't know if i should say that because i was like i
was like i was like that being my main takeaway from this
game from the trailer we can fight the invasion if i can't
save us i'm taking every last one of them with me
i feel like this is definitely this looks really fun though
i wonder how long it is it looks incredibly long 2017 i miss
when games took like more than a year to develop those were
the good old days now it's all about capitalism and dlcs one
of my personal favorite games of all time nice uh in a world
of mercia sims praise often labeled a masterpiece one of the
greats i wish i could forget the story and play this oh it's
like was it other wilds i'm okay like i was hanging out with
some friends and then like i just i was just like i just
like found out about this but um but basically outer wilds
there's like a server for people who like who love outer
wilds because apparently um the story is really good in
outer wilds that like uh that like people would try to
there's a server dedicated to finding other streamers who
are streaming other other wilds so they can live vicariously
through that streamer to re-experience other wilds and i
that blew my mind like it's like it's like gotcha viewers
there's like discord servers for like like fans of gotcha
games where like they would link streamers that are doing
gotcha polls so they live vicariously through streamers who
are doing polls because they don't want to do the polls
themselves but they want to live vicariously through that
streamer and that's why whenever like gotcha streamers do
polls their viewers their viewership like skyrockets really
high because they're like like if their channel gets linked
in those servers like it'll be like an at everyone this
streamer is doing a gotcha poll of this game and that's why
like their viewership like skyrocketed high for like
whenever they do polls because they want to live vicariously
through them but not spend the money this is the same with
elder wilds and i found this out because i have friends
trying to convince me to stream elder wilds so they could
watch my stream and live through me
because they're like you're like doki you have to stream
elder wilds i want to watch you play other wilds so like
because they're like if i could i wish i could wipe my
memory of this re-experience other wilds and i'm like what
the i was like what the fight no i even one of my friends is
actually in one of those outer wilds discords where like
they whenever someone's streaming other wilds they they
would like watch that streamer they don't care who that
streamer is they just want to live vicariously through that
streamer
It's actually crazy.
I did not know that.
Like, I didn't realize it had the same commute, like, the
same, like, impact that it does for gotcha games.
It's actually crazy.
Oh, there we go.
My one negative review cannot disable motion blur.
I like how that is the only negative review.
It's the only negative review here.
Wait, that sucks!
Wait, I can't disable...
You know, bro, that actually...
That sucks, though.
I cannot disable motion player.
Wait, that fucking sucks, though.
Wait, that actually...
That actually ruins a lot of games for me, not gonna lie.
Literally unplayable, honestly.
It's okay.
We're gonna try...
Pray.
Don't worry.
Lord Corrosus, thank you for the super...
Thank you for the Aka Super...
Thank you, thank you.
Yakuza fan base.
Also, I recommend Yakuza, but it's an RPG, so I will
recommend Devil May Cry 5.
The Devil May... Is that the one with the with the Emo Boy
main character?
Oh, no, that's not him.
Yeah, I will veto Yakuza because it's like a 100 plus hour
game.
And I don't know if I can...
I don't know if I I can't do that.
Oh, good.
It's not with the emo boy, Dante.
I love Devil May Cry.
I like how to say I love Devil May Cry, but I've only played
Devil May Cry 1.
It's because I grew up watching my dad play Devil May Cry.
I think I watched him play from 1 to 3.
And I personally played 1 myself on stream.
90% yes 10% liars who are the 10% that voted no show
yourself I love the concept I love watching my dad play
double may cry the music's really good though I think music
like makes or breaks a game
video near because like near is like a near is also like a
hundred plus hour game it's gonna take me it's gonna take me
forever to finish it
okay devil make cry is so cool i wish sex was real
177 people found this review helpful powerful.
Wait, why is the chair so powerful?
Only a hundred?
Well, you better go vote upvote that.
Better updute that.
What the fuck?
Okay, five stars.
Great.
Over years, I've been stabbed and jabbed by a number of
things.
Proceeds to stab myself.
Yes.
Oh my god, this is the first game with zero negative
reviews.
Guys!
It dropped from 90 to 89%?
What the fuck?
Who's the 11% that voted no?
What is it?
Oh my god.
This is the first game, guys.
The first no negative review game that we found.
Oh yeah.
Thank you for the super chat again for the suggestion.
Okay, here we go.
11% is not motivated.
All right.
And that is a yes.
I don't think we have a no yet.
uh let's see in memory of akira i recommend dragon ball z
kakura a fully uh comprehensive and expansive open world
dragon ball game going from start to finish for dragon ball
z currently 75 oh thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you wait i've like i've only played one dragon ball
okay it's not on steam guys
Oh, I just spelled it wrong.
Okay, wait.
Is it actually not on Steam?
Is it, like, a Steam exclusive?
Like, a Region Lot?
Wait, is it Region Lot?
Why is it not?
Do Canadians...
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck?
Why did it let me?
Oh, that's so weird.
Is this a fighting game?
The Dragon Ball game fans deserve a little Dragon Ball.
Rest in peace.
one of my uncles is a big fan of um the author um is this
but is this like a fighting game or is this it's an arpg
kind of rpg beat him up um and like not just dragon ball but
they basically owned like the whole okay let me i'm pretty
sure this is gonna be a yay up to 90 percent that makes me
as an Asian.
I love sales.
That makes me so happy.
But like, basically, I own...
Not own, sorry, my uncle.
This is the same uncle.
You guys don't remember the story.
But this is the same uncle who used to own lots of manga and
lots of like Gundam and everything.
And then he got married and the wife told him that he needed
to like get rid of that.
We're like, not half, but majority of his collection, it was
that uncle.
Anyway,
basically, before he got married, before he got married, I
would like, because like, he used to live with his parents,
and then, like, I would hang out with my grandparents at my
grandparents' place, and I would love to, like, hang out in
his room while he's, relax in his room while he was on his
PC doing, I don't know, whatever Otaku weeb shit he was
doing.
And I would like, I would like hang out, like, I would just
be like on his bed reading his manga collection.
So he had like a huge, like three bookcases filled with like
manga.
And I would like, and it would all be like in Chinese.
So I couldn't really read it, but I just love looking at the
um he basically had every single uh manga that uh that kira
published every single one of them like the one shots like
all his one shots that were put into manga form all like
everything like not just dragon ball but like uh dr slump
and every like obscure was like this one with this vampire
boy i don't remember the name of on the top of my head but
there was one with this vampire boy And then there was one
with this like fox child or whatever and like every single
one shot he would own He was like a super like Akira fanboy
and I would like read I would just read his manga It's not
Sandland.
It's not Sandland.
It was a one shot.
It had like 11 chapters, I think It's not Sandland.
It was basically like above he had it was like this ghost
fox That was like it's like this like little spirit fox
spirit or something thing and it would like and then he has
to save a hundred people yeah is it you have to save like a
hundred people to like become a person again and for some
reason that one shot was like stuck in my mind for the
longest time and i should reread it too i like um i reread
the manga for that because it was like when i heard about
him passing away it just unlocked like a core memory of my
hanging out in my uncle's room and just reading his manga
collection i think it is gogo gogo akman yeah yeah um i
would have to force her at the speed of light if my partner
asked me he has three kids together
guys they have three kids together
anyway um but yeah like i would i i just remember like just
um but yeah he was like a huge like he had every every just
everything i just remember he had the full collection of
dragon ball the full collection of dr slump every single
manga that he has published he owns it and he was a like
super Gundam builder um I'm I will not be seen the ones who
like Gundam I guess
um let's see rest in peace oh are you crying son no oh my
god who the fuck said who oh this was like before okay um oh
it's just Everybody hates DLC.
If it's super overpriced.
Alright.
That's a yay.
I don't think we have a...
Yeah, we don't have a single name yet.
Alright.
What's this?
Duck of life.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Alright.
What's this?
You know what?
I can't wait to play.
I need to get like people though.
I need to like recruit people.
Like it's so hard finding like people to play.
collabs like reaching out because i can't add everyone
anymore i can't i can't add everyone anymore i have to
actually social reach out to people
and there's one game i really want to play in this duck game
because it's such a fun game with friends i have to dm
people now
socializing i love duck game oh i already voted for this
this was a yay well this was a yay we don't need a we don't
need to look back i i'll i will give you guys previous yays
okay we don't have to we don't have to like vote again for
old yays i remember we yayed this we yay this before
because it has a 50 player co-op if you what like modded or
actual what do you do with 50 players and had in time isn't
this a platformer game isn't this how is this a 50 player
game how where where do the half the 50 players do I
remember when this game was a Kickstarter game.
The rare moment when Kickstarter games turned out okay.
By the way, I kickstarted that, what was it?
That rhythm game with, like, the boyfriend-girlfriend shit.
Fuck.
What was... Friday night Funkin'?
Bro, what the fuck is going on with that Kickstarter?
Like, I think...
Did the devs run away with our money?
There hasn't been an update to it In like Fuck a year plus I
feel like Bro did you hear the Did you hear the rumors Did
you guys hear the rumors That the dev is out there Fucking
Sipping Coca-Cola Read between the lines
I saw the fucking rumors and I was like what?
I don't know if it's true or not.
I don't know.
I just heard the rumors and I was like, and I looked at the
Kickstarter and I was like, there has not been an update in
a long time.
And I was like, what's going on?
What's going on?
It's not true.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Because, like, the thing is, there was plausible, like,
there could be plausible truth in it.
Because, like, ever since, because, like, a lot of Friday
Night Funkin' came from Newgrounds.
Yeah?
But the thing is, like, there has been, like, artists and,
like, voice actors that came from Newgrounds that spiraled
hard.
So I was like, I was like, okay, there could be like
plausible truth because of the, because due to, due to like
past experiences with other creators on Newgrounds.
So I couldn't, I was, okay, I have a lot of my humor and a
lot, like you can tell that I was a Newgrounds kid due to my
humor.
I grew up on Newgrounds.
Like, it's super fucking wild.
But, like, I didn't grow up on that side of Newgrounds.
There's, like, two sides of Newgrounds.
The one that's there for obvious, like, R18 shit.
And the other side that really enjoyed the games and
animations that were not those.
Like, so...
So, um...
So, is that Eagle Raptor?
Um, first time reviewing a game.
Got a cat here.
Friends passing by.
You can touch him and click like to pet him once.
This game is good.
Play it now.
The best 3D platform I played in a long time.
The thing is, there hasn't been like a lot of...
Like, 3D platformers are not the meta anymore.
So, there hasn't been a really...
Uh, like, uh, like...
platformers in general um you're a henry's no i was like
more of the edgy ones like i'd like the you know like the
the tank man and um back when ego raptor actually animated
stuff i was like so hyped for any like ego raptor animations
that would come out and also like uh obviously i shouldn't
be watching those things back then and uh and then also like
uh was it alice the alice return the alice games i remember
very fondly of i don't remember the what the game was called
the alice schemes and uh and then obviously like alien homin
like castle crashers when it was a new grounds game and
there's a lot of i just i remember like snippets of stuff
and then all the animation oh ed's world too that was on new
I remember when I saw a YouTube channel when he was like
talking about like his hospitalization and stuff and I was
like oh my god I was like like as a fucking that would gave
me like trauma Because I was a kid I like seeing that on
YouTube like I was like holy shit like as a kid seeing that
um No, no, it's like a new grounds game.
It's not American McGee's Alice great game, too.
I wish there was a sequel like I wish they made more because
I really enjoyed the lore and the art direction of Alice.
But, like, honestly, I heard, like, American McGee is very,
as a developer.
I'm trying to put this nicely.
Like, like, like,
I'm trying to figure out a way to put this nicely.
Oh, yeah, Alice is dead.
Alice is dead.
That's a good game.
That's on Newgrounds.
Like, that's a good game.
But he...
A bit of a diva, I would say.
A bit of a diva.
Let's see.
Yes.
Okay.
Hadden Tom.
That passes.
Let's see.
What else?
What else do we have?
What about Space Marine?
Uh, Imagina.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Be a big ass armor guy crushing Zenos.
Also, you should check bulk gun again to finish the job.
Okay.
Space Marine.
Ghost trick I wouldn't vote for it because honestly Ghost
trick I really want to play on my I really want to play it
in the future So we don't need a vote for that What's this
the retro 2011
I wish Gears of War was an Xbox exclusive or Microsoft
exclusive
OG I can't wait for the sequel The sequel looks really fun.
One force can halt the annihilation of mankind.
The Space Marine.
Weapons of steel.
For the Emperor!
Brothers!
I have known nothing about Warhammer except for the Space
Marines.
I feel like Every, like all the normies outside of the
space, like the Warhammer, the Warhammer fandom only knows
about the fucking Space Marines.
I don't know anything else about this game.
About the lore.
We are Space Marines.
Brothers, I am war.
Brothers, I can play this now, brothers.
Wait, what?
This game is crap.
like wait what i scroll down the first nick the first review
this game is great but what the fuck is this 60 for a decade
plus old game that's simply bundled together with dlc
there's nothing new in this anniversary edition raised up
price like a greedy mega corp just before i released a space
marine too pathetic
bro look at him didn't wait for this what the fuck 80% up
look at this guy didn't wait for that steam sale bro
literally could have waited a month later he's not a brother
the fool look at him
gonna say like that's just the nintendo way like that's but
when nintendo does it no one gives a about it or they're
just too scared to complain i'm too scared i'm honestly too
scared to play nintendo games on youtube i might need to ask
my manager how how to avoid how to avoid angering Nintendo.
Like, on Twitch, on Twitch, it's easier.
Because, like, the reason why, like, Nintendo, like, people
can stream Nintendo games very easily on Twitch is because,
like, the streaming policies on Twitch is a lot, like, like,
you can't really, like, copyright strike people on Twitch
regarding, other than music, for game-wise, it's like almost
impossible to do on twitch but like on youtube it's
obviously a lot of people like to abuse that system unless
yeah unless like you have like you have to sign up to
something because i remember like a long time ago i remember
reading about this that like you can like sign up to be like
a official nintendo content creator or something on on
youtube but you need to like apply for it or something like
that so they won't like automatically like strike your
videos when you're playing nintendo games um and that's for
like outside of like outside of japan so like i don't know
if that's still a thing i just need to ask mr man about it
so i don't know if the partners program is still a thing for
people uh in uh people in NA so I don't know it's not so
like I don't know like the thing is I don't want to piss off
Nintendo it's not I don't know I'm not updated in like the
new shit of what Nintendo wants now so like I need to see
it's no longer a thing okay all right um but even then I
need to make sure that everything is okay when it comes to
me streaming Nintendo games on YouTube I'm Nintendo is like
one of the I don't Nintendo is like one of the only
companies that I'm scared of when it comes to like game
permissions every other like because like every other time
um through like history whenever like any other company but
Nintendo like try to strike somebody on YouTube it turns
into huge news and stuff because people would be like whoa
that's a little extreme so no companies want to risk that
and stuff because like it just gives negative publicity but
like nintendo wise is the only company i'm scared of when it
comes to game programs with things like that so that's why
i'm not risking it like i need to make sure i am safe when
it comes to nintendo games um but also like imo there's like
not really a lot of nintendo games i would want to like
actually stream um because like uh um i'm not like i don't
know there's like i'm not like i didn't grow up with
nintendo so i don't have the huge nostalgia factor playing
in on anything and the only thing i like about pokemon is
like the og like i'm not a fan of the new pokemon series
other than the legends stuff they've done but like because
legends was like new it was like a new way of doing pokemon
um But other than that, I didn't grow up with nostalgia for
Nintendo games because I didn't grow up.
Like, my dad didn't let me play Nintendo games because I
didn't have consoles for it.
So I literally have zero nostalgia for Nintendo.
So like, whenever like a new Nintendo game comes out, I'm
not like, like it doesn't really affect me too much type.
deal uh i prefer crash bandicoot uh racing game versus the
mario kart i honestly think the crash bandicoot racing game
is better than mario kart for me like after playing both of
them i like the crash bandicoot one more yeah the dad moves
too strong um let's see all right space marine that is a yay
i feel bad for the first person who gets the name i'm so
sorry if you're in the first one uh let's see uh uh uh uh uh
uh great thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i
heard somebody say project nexus i concur 100 that is a
great game Project Nexus.
What is that?
Let's see.
Wait, I know this game.
Wasn't this a Newgrounds game?
Or was this from a Newgrounds creator?
I've seen their animation.
Yeah, I've seen their animation.
I told you, I'm a Newgrounds.
I grew up on Newgrounds.
Like, I recognize this.
Yeah, I recognize this
This room looks This reminds me of Fuck, what is that?
Hotline Miami?
It's like feels The gameplay seems very similar To Hotline
Miami Is a third person Run and gun Being about Filled with
arcade style action 20 2021 oh this is recent 2021 let's see
i don't know if it's good or not i think i need to play what
holy i was like wait what do you mean bro this man has 857.7
hours bro what okay i need i need i need to see if his
account's public like what the fuck Jesus Christ Guys I
think he really likes I think he really likes this game guys
I didn't think I love madness combat I love madness combat I
love madness combat She yanked all my What?
Oh she hate What?
That doesn't make more sense to me I regret refunding this
game Okay peak gaming right here I can grab a fire
extinguisher and beat people a little bit 10 out of 10 all
right check this guy's like profile all right guys i think
he really likes project next bro bro he got everything holy
shit sorry for doxing you bro bro he has all the
achievements holy shit bro maybe maybe he really likes
project nexus guys i think he really likes this game guys
holy fuck bro his review is i i gotta play more his review
was like i gotta play more to make me sure oh my he knows he
knows what's up he really really really likes it um leam
thank you for the magenta soup Thank you.
Thank you.
Rain World is a 2D survival platformer where you are the
prey animal in a simulated ecosystem.
The other wilds is a 3D...
Okay, other wilds, I'm definitely going to do it in the
future.
Due to peer pressure.
Due to peer pressure from my friends.
So, like, don't worry about that.
That you don't need to vote.
Okay, Rain World.
Let's see.
What is this?
You're a nomadic slug cat, both predator and prey, and a
broken ecosystem.
Grab your spear and brave the industrial waste, hunting each
food to survive.
But be wary.
Other bigger creatures have the same plan.
And slug cats look delicious.
It's like jelly.
You'll suffer in this platformer.
That's the trailer?
Does it just end like that?
Oh, I guess it's like gameplay trailer.
I was gonna be like, wait, what the?
It just ends.
Where's Predator?
I'm mad that Mark.
Okay, how long is this game, though?
It might be a reason why you didn't finish it.
Because, like, for...
Okay.
Variety streamers.
Here's, like, a little streamer tip for you guys.
is that unless you're like you're like a certain focused
gaming stream like in terms of like your focus on like a
certain genre for variety streamers there is a limit on like
how they think is like viewer retention and at point because
in the past let's plays were very common it's very common to
do let's plays but streamer meta has evolved to the extent
where like if you're a streamer um you can't you can't do
long let's plays anymore or you have to do edited content uh
because like so unless you're like a heavy focused genre for
a specific genre you can get away with that but you're in
variety streaming longer gameplay playthroughs are now not
meta anymore so so it's like obviously the more you play the
same game uh the more you play the same game the the
multiplayer multiplayer obviously the multiplayer games it's
like competitive and stuff but you're playing if you're a
variety streamer uh it's harder to keep up so like for me my
i've learned that my hard limit for like for like uh long
playthroughs is three to four three to four streams usually
that's the average so like my goal is to always complete a
game within three to four streams because that is like the
viewer retention and everything.
So it's like, you gotta figure out like what is your like
hard limit when it comes to like longer playthroughs of
streams because when you play the same game for a very long
time, people will like eventually get super bored of it.
And that's like the biggest issue of being a variety
streamer.
Let's see.
I wish somebody would make a world of rain.
It's because it's because short form content ruined us like
tick tock and YouTube like like tick tock and YouTube what
the it's fun to die over and over and over and over and what
the fuck But yeah the tick tock and YouTube shorts basically
brain rotted a lot of people
um there is no other game to my knowledge that does what
rain world does there's no other game that can create an
environment this alien alive and what the fuck are they is
it playing the same thing again oh i didn't pause it i was
like what the fuck am i listening oh yeah if you're more of
a casual gamer do not recommend it i grew up gave up after
barely getting a third of the story on easy mode what bro
wait no he didn't he kept playing so this liar oh oh there
we go there you go the above paragraph was what was eight
hours now after 40 hours i beat the game in easy mode but
cheating sometimes by using the warp mod because the game
got on my nerves bro this man modded his game so he can
finish it faster on easy that's not a casual gamer that's
journalism mode i'm so sorry if you're watching the stream
um but like you gotta accept that like that's not being at
that point like you're not a casual gamer at that point
that's like actually like like you're below casual gamer
the fun i had playing it in some parts was offset by
frustrations that adds nothing to the game in my opinion i
would have loved the game if it was like katana zero where
the checkpoint is at every screen or something of the sort
the problem is not having to deal with a challenging
situation the problem is having passed all through the easy
part you already passed so that you face the challenge again
bro this guy should never play a souls game
okay uh let's see oh i played call of horace before said
thank you for the magenta super thank you thank you we
played it before um like i said before um you guys didn't
know i played these games before you can there if you look
hard enough you'll find an archive you look hard enough
You'll find an archive of it.
Let's see.
Shark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bomb Rush Cyber Funk.
Really fun gameplay and amazing aesthetic.
All right, here you go.
Let's see.
What is this?
Whoa.
Whoa, this music.
Wait, is this a spiritual successor of...
What was it?
This is a spiritual successor.
Oh, Justin Radio!
Yes!
Justin Radio!
This is basically like Justin Radio.
I've always wanted to play Justin Radio.
I wish there was a remaster of the rapping game.
What was it?
Paparapa?
I forgot his name.
I didn't grow up with that game, but I've always wanted to
play it.
Loud.
Okay.
I wish they did a remaster of that.
I've never played it.
I've always seen memes about it.
And by that, I meant the one that I remember is the one with
Batman.
This is where my parents died.
Alright, let's see.
What are the reviews?
Exploring 5.
spots and get the rep you'll need to challenge the rival
crew is this skateboarding oh yeah it is skateboarding this
is just set radio three wait why why do we need to play this
game with bro what the fuck what is he why please play this
game with mods i know people judge me for this but i only
ever bought this game because i saw someone playing as sonic
i thought that was incredible a real thing made me happy and
the fact that i can add my okay there's even multiplayer
mode but like why does he have so many mods what are all
these disable annoying cutscenes final score does give me my
boost rebound custom group just sit down photo storage whoa
bro that is so many mods that's not just sonic to get you
started like better What the fuck does better...
What the fuck does BRC toilet mean?
Better toilet?
Why is there a toilet function?
My favorite Sonic model is the 06 model pack.
It has a tendency to crash games.
I don't think it's this mod that has a tendency to crash
games.
all of this
I like how he's like yeah by the way this mod tends to crash
games I'm like no!
Look at all these mods you have!
Holy shit!
Oh my god okay and you should be good holy fuck like yeah
modding's great and all but this is way too many for like
this is not skyrim this is not skyrim this is fucking bomb
rush cyberpunk like better toilet is crucial you seriously
yeah i was gonna say this looks like a fucking skyrim mod
will get you laid nice nice all right hey don't change shame
you should see my armor three mod list uh let's see come up
thank you for the magenta soup thank you thank you okay i've
always wanted to play hollow night but i heard it's like
it's like such a long-term commitment i feel like i rather
i'm gonna i'm the reason why i haven't played hollow night
yet is that i'm low-key for uh i'm waiting for like the
sequel of hollow night um because like that's the one i'm
waiting for i only i need to do a yay or nay for this but
like i've always wanted to play it hollow night is like one
of those games that even though i know it's like a super
long game it's like i'm honestly like super curious but i
honestly sort of want to wait for silk song wait what do you
mean it's not wait what What do you mean?
What do you mean it's not coming out?
There are so many trailers!
What do you mean?
Don't say that!
There are so many trailers!
Every...
Don't come out!
No!
Brennan, yes!
But that's what you know is a good game!
That's when you know, guys!
You just gotta believe!
Guys, guys, we don't want it to be like all the other one
fast track games.
Don't worry, I will wait a hundred years for the sequel.
For a game I've never played before.
the sequel of a game I'll never play 300k reviews that's
actually honestly I'm curious I'm curious who fucking gave a
negative review like it's oh wait there's a guy right now
obviously I'm not far enough in the game though I still love
the art style I find the game far too okay is it all the
negative reviews just skill issue you are but grim is hot
silk song okay so song is a lie okay um i don't know what
the negative reviews are for this okay negative that's like
9 000 our official all of this are like What even infected
my dreams?
Don't buy it if you have in Kingdom.
Map system sucks.
What the fuck?
Sex the Hornet.
Stop looking at negative reviews and buy this game.
I love how like, uh, good game I just have skill issue.
All of the negative reviews are just like skill issue.
I'm not good enough for this game.
He knows.
Garlics, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Don't wait for Silk Song.
Hollow Knight is one of the best Metroidvania games ever
made.
If not the best.
Nobody who enjoys Metroidvania-style games should go without
playing it.
Bro, this guy, I bet you, this guy.
This guy was the one that wrote this review.
Silk Song is the one.
it's him it's him it's true all right all right we're gonna
look at we're gonna look at uh I'll give you guys three more
games guys we're gonna look at three more games and then
we're gonna call it here we're gonna call it here I don't
think it was a super chat thank you thank you I second
inscription it's one of my favorite games and it's one game
of the year when it came out like deck builder is that like
this wasn't there like a new like roguelike card game that
came out as well i don't remember what it's called um it is
uh what was that game called the newest one i almost said
baruto i was like wait no that's the sequel of naruto i uh
it was so similar Who the fuck is this guy that's streaming
it?
And it's not me.
Let's see.
Um.
What was it?
Balaltro?
I've heard about this game.
This game was like a streaming meta game.
Uh, when it came out.
Inscription.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I heard like the Laotro seems to be like a really fun
game.
I've seen a lot of people playing it when it came out.
I don't know what it really is, though.
I've never really been like a card game player.
I have no idea what to do.
Like...
Because it requires a lot of reading.
And a lot of like using your brain.
Which is honestly like one of my negative traits.
um not the reading part i can read but just i can read by
the way it's more so of of the uh it's more so the thinking
part uh let's see i actually don't know how to play poker i
watched my dad play poker my dad would play like this um
after um like he would play those like oh my gosh if you
lived in Asia you would know those card games like the one
with the like the online it's not like it's like Chinese
online poker where like there was like avatars and stuff and
you can like dress up your little avatar it was like a blue
background and then you can like dress up your avatars and
stuff like it was like Gaia online and I would just watch
him play that game and and then like the more money you win
the more you can decorate your avatar and it was so because
like it's like a point like you don't win real money but it
was like point system and stuff no it was poker it was like
it was so funny so like you didn't tell like who doesn't
have money because they're naked they will be on their
underwear and then and then like my dad was like super
decked out
it was like super decked out with like and everything and
there's like cutscenes there's like animations if you win
the game
that's so dumb um let's see why are you reading this just
play it and play along he turned the computer into a
funniest shit I've ever seen surpassed all my expectations
go in blind don't look anything up one of the games I played
so much effort sweet thank you for the 20 get the chips
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, okay.
It seems like you have to go in line for this.
It seems like a cool game.
But just me learning the basics makes my head hurt.
Head hurt.
Tell me hurt.
Don't worry, bro.
That's going to be me.
0.3 hours refunded.
That's going to be me, guys.
That's going to be me.
head hurt brain hurt um let's see it sleeping dogs uh hey
boy thank you for that super chat thank you thank you we're
not gonna do yay or nay or sleeping dogs but that's because
that's one of the games that i want to play in the future
this is one of the games i want to play in the future so
we're not we don't have to vote for sleeping dogs uh let's
see what else uh
What else?
I'm looking at, like, indie game suggestions.
Gee, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
King of the castle.
It has Twitch integration so you can play against all the
dragoons in the chat.
You play as the queen while all your chat are backstabbing
nobles trying to dethrone you.
It's only, like, seven bucks.
Okay.
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
It's not fair.
You're all just gonna fucking dethrone me.
fair what could go wrong in telling these ice warriors i'm
their king like why would i play this with you guys you're
all just gonna try and like sabotage me it's not even gonna
be a question
that's the idea
god that's a lot of politics
we would never how could you say that about us is that i
don't know what's going on i don't know what's going on in
this game in king of the castle you wear the crown make
difficult choices that will bring your kingdom into
prosperity or chaos of course you won't be ruling alone
Wait, only three people.
I thought it was like, oh, unless like the Twitch
integration can be like one person.
I'm too dumb for this.
Don't worry, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Once they've joined the game, they will vote on your
decisions and provide you with...
Oh, you can do teens.
or at least you hope so more likely they'll scheme to take
the throne for themselves king of the castle wishlist now
all right what are the comments your majesty there's no such
thing as absolute powers and what's the point what's the
what's what's the point then it really depends who you're
playing with the nobles have to be really into the screen
and commit it i think nobles need a little more to do more
magic more intrigued it's a nice party game but stay away we
have a wide screen or ultra wide screen okay i got murdered
three times by my friends repeatedly but i kept coming guys
this is gonna be me guys this is i'm vetoing this wait what
my friend got killed by jesus 10 out of 10 game guys i'm
vetoing this you guys are just How am I supposed to enjoy
it?
I'm vetoing.
This is my only video.
I'm vetoing this.
I'm going to veto this.
No, I had...
That's one...
I've only vetoed once.
And this was the only video.
This is literally the only video that I've had.
Like, I'm not going to let you guys...
Like, you killed me non-stop.
all right last game suggestion this is gonna be the last
game suggestion guys uh last one uh okay let's see which one
should i oh this is gonna be this is gonna be scary which
last game are we gonna play let's see uh what is this peaks
of your you know what lance good good job for you because
this is a game i've never heard before peaks of your what is
this okay no
this is my second veto we got another suggestion we can look
guys i'm gonna look for one more suggestion we're not doing
peaks of yard this is veto number two
okay okay we're gonna all right who wants to give me that
last game suggestions all right here we go
i don't need a try it's a climbing game i don't need a look
it's literally a climbing game What do you mean?
I didn't give it a try.
We already have a climbing game.
We don't need another climbing game, guys.
We don't need another one.
What the fuck?
Garfield lasagna party?
Okay, this is... Okay, this... I just need you... Oh, I look
how it says so it's like.
This is not multiplayer.
This is local player.
It's not a veto.
It's more like it's impossible to play with anybody Because
it's a local It's not online multiplayer It's local player I
know because I actually looked it up And the reviews were
like Oh you can't fucking play with people online Alright
This would be the last game suggestions From Deadpool
Last suggestion of the day
Clamp game.
Thank you for the super chat.
God, thank you, thank you.
What is this?
Is this just an animated trailer?
It's a reverse horror game in which you...
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait, I think I've seen this game before.
I think I know what this game...
Oh my god.
You are the spooky monster.
So what's the difference?
Nice.
I consume all
What?
Oh, he got He got hit Oh
Oh, God Oh, God, where's the gameplay Oh, there it is Dude,
can you die?
Wait, they can't shoot How do you shoot a blob of mass
there's no head at that point yeah it's like the thing oh
god it's like this is like rated rated it's like r18 super
meat boy wait this is this is like a super meat boy this is
this is if super meat boy went hollywood
You are the blob.
A Super Meat Boy sold out and went to Hollywood.
And Super Meat Boy, but he eats.
A Mega Meat Boy.
The Netflix adaptation.
Wait, true.
This is the Netflix adaptation of Super Meat Boy.
Alright, it's a puzzle game.
Why would it be a puzzle?
I just eat.
Oh, oh, it's Editor's Choice Award.
Nice.
E3, rest in peace.
Salute.
Really relaxing game going around eating every human being
that you see.
I ate people in this game.
Noodle Elder Sauce.
Best game I've ever played in my whole life.
God, I love.
Yes, look.
I'm fucking, bro.
Same mine.
Bro, this guy.
New best friend.
The real super meat boy.
I fucking knew it I've only played for three hours but it's
been mouthful of content wait what okay is this I swear if
this is skill issue the novelty of playing as a monster
wears off fairly quickly once you realize there really isn't
much challenge overall and the level design boils down to
finding new few switches to open doors more interesting
mechanics start to get introduced near the end however the
game as a whole short and they don't do much with this is
another skill issue is this another skill issue um actually
um the novelty wears off very quickly it's not hard enough
but it gets so boring too
it's reverse skilled issue he's actually kind of right no It
was this game is too confusing actually
Just be worse at the game to enjoy them Either be worse at
the game so we can enjoy games again Or be better at games
so you can enjoy them Alright and that was our last
recommendation Every game recommendation has passed Every
game you guys suggested other than the ones I vetoed Made it
through.
We got, let's see.
I know one of my mods was making a list.
Are you still here?
Can you give me my list?
We approved.
Amid evil.
Brutal legend.
Halo.
EDF.
Oh yeah!
Wait, we have to have a poll.
I almost forgot.
Which version of EDF?
4.1 or 5?
Alright.
We almost forgot the poll.
Okay, so almost every game that was suggested by you guys
made it to the finals and won.
So we got EDF, whichever version that wins.
Guruman, Prey, Devil May Cry 5, Dragon Ball Z, Sign, Hat and
Time, Space Marine, Project Nexus, Rain World, and Carry On,
an inscription, and Bomb Rush, Cyberpunk.
Oh my god, so many games.
at least i i save money on the steam cell love saving money
lads damn i can't believe doki doesn't appreciate the
widespread appeal of games without the 1800 civil about the
1800 civil age of climbing one of these days i'll fire
vtuber who play the scottish mountain game thank you for the
super chat thank you thank Thank you.
One of these days, somebody will play my favorite game about
Scottish climbing.
That is like a very, very specific niche you have there,
sir.
That is extremely specific.
Someday you will find that streamer.
Someday, I believe in you.
He's going to be on a live stream.
long search all right but yeah that was really fun though i
had a really great time like looking up uh looking up steam
games with all of you guys and reading the reviews i'm sorry
like it wasn't it was only i like i like put my cut off at
like two hours because like i wanted to rest a little bit
today so that's why i had to cut the stream to two hours
today um so i didn't do a lot of uh I want to do more game
suggestions, but I don't want to overdo it because I don't
want to overdo myself with getting burnt out and everything.
So that's why I had a little cutoff for myself.
Anyway, I hope you guys had a great time.
I had a great time talking with a lot of you guys and
hanging out and just looking at video games together.
It looks like five is winning.
So I'm going to do a countdown for everybody for the last
final vote in which I don't think, I honestly don't think
4.1 is going to win looking at these numbers, but I will
entertain the thought about giving guys more time to vote.
So 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1, and pull.
Yeah, EDF 5 wins in the end.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing
interview so for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye